[Music]
on my trip
police say and I went to Paris got an
Airbnb across the street from the Eiffel
Tower Eiffel Towers right out our
bedroom window
I hope my name in the bathroom of the
Eiffel Tower on the second story out I
said if I ever went back to Paris I
would look for it maybe we can do that
first and makeover yeah this is Paris
you're still on there would you know
it's not gonna be good at our Airbnb
it's a really old neighborhood so people
have been living there their whole lives
we stayed on the sixth floor the top
floor of the building classy no elevator
there's a spiral old wooden staircase
god only knows how many people have died
in that building well the second day the
sixth floor started to smell now we go
walk through Paris for the day when we
get back and an ambulance outside the
building the door opens ready firm about
to pull on it and a medic walks out and
he I see him pull out a wheelchair and I
see it and it'll be 50 year old lady on
there and then the second medic comes
carrying the other side not a wheelchair
it's a stretcher as its battling with
their eyes open a whole upper body of
modern face and as the second medic
looked at us and he goes lit or eight
Nate just gives us like a debt-based
look like if you can prove that like
yeah he's dead seen this before we get
there and we're going up the stairs and
we realize
her doors is now open
she's been dead in that apartment for a
week or so and there's a big window to
the Sun and they're all negative nice a
toasty oh damn I wonder what she was
doing like what what she was doing when
she passed was she sitting by a window
thinking like this is it you know they
really weren't kidding when they said
you'd die alone
so did I tell you about the the exorcism
so this past summer we were approached
by YouTube originals put together a
YouTube bread series being electrical
thing is send me on Channel me on
corridor we keep talking about these
different projects we're doing big
projects are coming up this one's super
cool this one's called lifeline lifeline
is going to be a reality show or nico in
myself have to survive in a hospital for
two nights and if we have to scared and
we run out and we lose the game it could
be a half hour long episode that's not
my life line is telling Minority Report
meet looper a little bit it can be cool
however it's not all fun and game we're
just growing a lot of really unique
problems that one must deal with as you
get into this kind of stuff everyone go
like eight making a big project wait you
have a bigger budget how are there more
problems well as the wise man once said
more money more problems the funny one
here's an example we would get in really
big trouble if we're on set and I did
something like this
that would literally like to shut the
production down we're actually not
allowed to touch the cameras a lot of
Dutch cameras isn't that yes that we're
director yeah so the thing is this is a
union show once the budget gets big
enough if you're trying to hire talent
people to be part of the union and you
have to pay union seeds need to follow
the union rules I don't know how all
this works makes no sense we're figuring
it out as they go yeah but the point is
that it's a little weird for us because
for the last 15 years all we do is we
just touch cameras all day I guess I
guess our challenge here is figuring out
a way to navigate a set just as
directors not as camera operators not as
cinematographers not as the economy
InDesign errs not as the effects artists
and supervisors I am a little scared to
be honest really yeah but what just get
a supply pipeline from the creators of
name of the GoPro the creator's who
brought you
dubs of gum stuff yeah from the
directing team that brought you
Jason boring cook Thanksgiving not to
reckon the union too hard there's a lot
of good rules in place such as like not
being all the work your crew for 18
hours straight without a lunch break
just like other jobs and other
occupations film crews have unions as
well which the in these unions serve to
just kind of regulate working hours pay
safety standards movie shows are
exceptionally dangerous but people die
every year in film sets this past year a
person was killed on the set of the new
Resident Evil movie when a Humvee fill a
platform crushed them and a stunt woman
was nearly killed when she rammed your
camera cream and ship faces degloved
defaced ya unions basically they serve
to just generally set standards and to
protect lawyers and workers that's weird
because some really weird rules cannot
yeah
rulz come out of it such as not being
able to touch the camera because camera
Union literally Heather all stating that
to their workers that only they are
allowed to touch the camera and if
anyone else violates that on set then
they're going to throw and pull out
their support for project it's going to
be a challenge Sam and I will have to be
perfect communicators we're going to
just stand back grant to watch
everything and communicate exactly what
we want or we do have another solution
we came up with that might solve the
problem you're going to have a retain
the camera here so we'll take the Union
camera operator here so if you're
filming a shot hi tell me that the
director what do you want the shot to be
well first frame about this subject you
see in front of us all right
there will am three two one action
time there you go yeah keep it steady hi
Daddy
there your ever dying cool camera
problems avoided didn't touch the camera
touch the camera they're going to come
for me family I'm going to we're going
to learn to be better directors through
all day we're going to learn how to
actually direct the communicators on big
bunch of the film
well actually I take the back I'm think
budget of the directors still operate
the camera Michael Bay does it James
Cameron does it but you know what the
stepping stone up to the big boy leagues
there's gonna be a little bit more in
time we're awesome the cameras up to
part ways so today we have a sponsor
that I'm actually really excited about
because the Forest Service but I use
every single day and that is audible
it makes next meets way more interesting
weight makes my walk way more
interesting because you're listening to
part they're great
look at all these books you can listen
to it delete them from your phone after
you're done originally I drove down to
Oregon because I went up there for the
holidays and a book I listen to which
was like a nine-hour show is we are
legion we are Bob and if you've ever
read the Martian you will love this book
there's this guy he takes an insurance
claim out on his life and so that in the
event that he dies I chop off his head
and freezes brain in the hopes that they
can revive him someday instead what
happens is that he wakes up a hundred
years later to learn that he is now a
state-owned AI the earth is falling
apart humanity is crumbling and so in a
last-ditch effort
save themselves they send this von
Neumann probably can google it out into
the world into the solar system into the
galaxy as an AI he's able to think super
fast like milliseconds are minutes to
him and he clones himself as an AI 3 is
up with like multiple different versions
of himself he's talking with them it's
really cool because all the characters
in this book are 210 with slightly
different personalities but they all
have the same memories anyway also has
like an unmatched selection of audio
books original audio shows news comedy
whatever you want to listen to you can
probably listen to it on audible in fact
you can actually download this book
right now by signing up for a free 30
day trial today at audible.com slash Sam
and Nico download this book keep it
forever even if you end the service I
use it every single day so I'd recommend
keeping it all you vote on the word of
the read don't know if that's on there
but anything from Brandon Sanderson
fantastically is my favorite author tons
of his works on there Harry Potter is
also on and yeah you can get Harry
Potter and get miss adore undercut you
can get huh the director's cut right of
an audiobook ok recover if he's not the
director's cut I don't you can not yeah
I hate you so much right now